NATASHA ROMANOFF
You don't know everything about me.
I've lived a lot
of lives.
♪♪
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Before I was an Avenger...
Before I got this family...
I made mistakes...
Choosing between what the
world wants you to be...
And who you are.
♪♪
NATASHA ROMANOFF
We have to go back
to where it all started.
YELENA BELOVA
Where did you think I was all this time?
NATASHA ROMANOFF
We have unfinished business.
♪♪
ALEXEI SHOSTAKOV
My girls...
...are the toughest
girls in the world.
MELINA VOSTOKOFF
I'm sorry. We had our orders,
and we played
our roles.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
It wasn't real.
♪♪
YELENA BELOVA
It was real to me.
To me...
...you were everything.
DREYKOV
Bring her...
...home.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Put your seat belts on.
YELENA BELOVA
You're such a mom.
♪♪
NATASHA ROMANOFF
One thing's for sure.
I'm done running
from my past.
♪♪